So one of the things that's really
interesting about psychoanalysis,
so one of the things I love about it is
that psychoanalyst tell you if someone
says I'm good,
okay,
or I stand for a good thing,
the first thing you want to look
for is the opposite of that.
It's like,
okay,
that's what you say.
What might really be going on?
Or is it actually the case that you're
Jesus Christ and all the saints combined?
You know,
you're this perfect person or there are
there dark motives for what you're doing
that you claim to be doing for the good.
So guy named George Orwell,
who was one of the world's
most creative essayists in,
in,
in this in the 20th century,
he was a,
he was a left winger.
He wrote some things
that were very criticism,
critical of socialist
movements and what did,
it was one of the early critics of of
Soviet Russia when it was sort of in vogue
among intellectuals to be
supportive of the Soviets.
One of the things he said about left wing
socialist was that they didn't really
like the poor.
He was talking about middle class,
left wing socialist,
not the working class guys who
were in unions and you know,
had some justification for their struggle
against those who are at the top of
the power hierarchy was more looking at
people that were already at the top of
the power hierarchy,
who are claiming to be
advocates for the working class.
You know,
and his claim fundamentally was that
those people didn't like the poor.
They just hated the rich.
And you know,
that's the,
it was difficult for the publisher
who was publishing that book,
which was called
MMM.
Road to Wigan pier,
which is an amazing book.
It's a book about coal miners in northern,
in northern Britain and it's,
it's brutal.
Those people at brutal lives,
man.
So,
but anyways,
uh,
you know,
the publisher,
which was the left book club,
if I remember correctly,
was very low to publish the essay that
went along with that book because it was
such a devastating criticism of sort
of middleclass socialism anyways.
Anyways,
so the psychoanalysts
are always telling you,
look,
you know,
there you are,
there's no monster.
It's like,
okay,
where's the monster?
Because it's somewhere,
it's somewhere because
there's a monster in everyone.
And if you're hiding it or covering
it up or pretending that you know,
you only stand for the good.
It's like all that means is that you're
ignorant and naive about your own
possibility.
There's a monster around there somewhere.
So,
yeah.
And that's partly because,
you know,
if you're not a monster,
it's pretty hard to stay
alive because you know,
you have to contend with things like this,
sorry,
things like this and things like this and
things like this and things like this,
you know,
that's your life.
You contend with that nature is brutal.
Culture is brutal,
and other people can be brutal too.
And so if you're not prepared for
that and able to withstand it,
then you're just going to get rolled over.
So you better get the old inner
monster developed because,
and under conscious control because
even though it's a terrible thing,
you need it.